uno de los hermanos sanderson fue
encontrado sin vida los dos sospechosos
del apuñalamiento múltiple en el que
diez personas murieron y 19 resultaron
heridas en una comunidad indígena al
noreste del país habían huido tras uno
de los ataques más violentos en la
historia reciente de canadá puede
terminan sanderson fue encontrado cerca
al lugar de los hechos su cuerpo fue
localizado al aire libre en una zona con
mucho césped en las proximidades de una
casa que estaba siendo investigada
podemos confirmar que tiene varias
heridas visibles
la búsqueda continúa cientos de agentes
siguen tras el rastro de mails anderson
aseguran que podría estar en la ciudad
de regina la capital de saskatchewan y
que es probable que esté herido el
segundo de los anderson había infringido
su libertad condicional la condena que
estaba cumpliendo por los delitos de
asalto robo conducta maliciosa y
amenazas los habitantes de la comunidad
siguen conmocionados
no esperaba despertarme el domingo
escuchando esto ahora estoy aterrorizada
de irme a dormir por la noche
aterrorizada de abrir mi puerta el
primer ministro canadiense yo sin sudo
condenó el ataque y aseguró que está
trabajando con las autoridades locales
los ataques de ayer en saskatchewan son
impactantes y desgarradores mis
pensamientos y los pensamientos de todos
los canadienses están con aquellos que
han perdido a sus seres queridos y con
aquellos que están heridos este tipo de
violencia o cualquier tipo de violencia
no tiene cabida en nuestro país las
cifras de apuñalamientos fatales en
canadá han ido en aumento en los últimos
años en 2021 se registraron 242 más de
los 237 reportados en 2020